[Applaudissements]
j'ai 76 ans je suis monitrice de plongée
sous-marine et mon animal fétiche et le
grand requin blanc
au commencement il y a eu la peur la
peur de l'eau mais qui parmi vous n'a
jamais eu peur de l'eau du vide du
serpent de parler en public
la peur est inscrite dans l'histoire de
l'homme
elle est bien souvent un frein sa
liberté
mais comment faire quand on a une peur
phobique de l'eau qqun sait pas nager
mais qu'ont-ils curieux curieux de
découvrir l'autre facette de la planète
le monde sous marin
comme beaucoup d'entre vous je suis de
la génération du commandant cousteau et
ses films nous ont fait rêver
et puis un jour je me suis dit mais
c'est quand même pas l'eau qui est un
problème mais c'est moi qui ait un
problème avec tôt alors j'ai voulu en
chercher les causes
bien sûr il y avait le rejet de ma mère
et puis le suicide d'une soeur dans
l'eau que je dû reconnaître
trois semaines plus tard quand on l'a
retrouvé je pensais bien avoir fait le
deuil de tout cela mais la peur était
toujours là alors je me suis dit je vais
aller dans les profondeurs je vais faire
de la plongée sous-marine a les dents
mais profondeur mais à cette seule idée
je faisais des cauchemars toutes les
nuits
replongeons-nous 41 ans en arrière en ce
temps là les clubs de plongée était
surtout composée d'hommes plutôt du
genre macho les femmes y étaient rares
et pas les bienvenus alors quand on
arrive dans ce milieu qu'on ne sait pas
nager et qu'on a peur de l'eau on peut
pas dire qu'on soit bien accepté
mais plus grande frayeur ont bien été en
piscine pendant des mois j'ai appris
seule la plongée sous marine
je descendais à l'échelle je me
cramponnait je mettais ma tête sous
l'eau j'essayais de balle mais un
moniteur m'a dit un jour tu devrais
arrêter tu vas finir par te noyer au
bord de la piscine malgré la pression
des plongeurs malgré les cauchemars que
je faisais toutes les nuits j'ai
continué d'aller toutes les semaines
quatre heures à la piscine pour essayer
d'apprendre un peu l'apogée et
d'apprivoiser ma peur en même temps j'ai
appris à nager
et puis un jour un moniteur madlib
écoute je pensais que c'était pour me
récompenser mon assiduité
on va te faire passer le niveau 1 il y a
parmi vous des plongeurs en suis
persuadé
vous savez que le niveau 1 c'est
vraiment le minimum de ce qu'il faut
savoir pour pouvoir aborder la plongée
ce niveau un jeu les passés quatre fois
et à la quatrième fois je crois bien
qu'on me la donner
et puis un jour le club dit on organise
une plongée en bretagne dans la cale de
plumes l'après perros guirec
je me suis inscrite pour plonger en
bretagne les moniteurs qui devait
m'encadrer n'était pas du tout rassuré
moi non plus d'ailleurs
quand je suis rentré dans la mer
symbolisme des mots tout peur s'est
évanoui ma curiosité a pris le dessus
j'ai vu enfin ce monde sous marin dans
sa réalité
à partir de ce jour là je n'ai plus
jamais eu peur de l'eau je continue à
apprendre la plongée j'ai passé tous les
niveaux du monitorat fédéral au brevet
d'état
enseigner a toujours été dans mon chemin
de vie et puis je vous dire apprendre la
plongée c'est comme d'apprendre à
conduire un véhicule
c'est simplement une technique un peu
d'entraînement aussi mais quand on n'a
pas peur
c'est tellement plus facile mais dans le
monde de la mer il y à des requins
et en écoutant les autres plongent
sommes parlé des requins qu'il
rencontrait dans la mer j'étais un peu
comme vous il y avait un peu
d'inquiétude je me disais mais quand je
un jour dans le monde sous marin je vais
rencontrer un requin comment ça va se
passer et c'est ce qui m'est arrivé un
jour où elles vivent j'ai vu mon premier
regard et j'ai été fasciné par cet
animal
alors j'ai voulu comprendre pourquoi il
faisait peur
si je vous demande à quoi vous fait
penser le mot requins vous allez me dire
gable sans monstre sous marin mangeur
d'hommes rassurez vous messieurs
ils mangent aussi les femmes et les
enfants est-il aussi dangereux que cela
dix morts par an dans le monde entier
tour aucun confondues alors que pendant
la même période les vaches du 100
personnes nos amis les chiens 25000
c'est vrai qu'ils transportent la rage
et plus ont un serial killer deviner le
moustique 725 mille personnes et pendant
la durée de mon intervention
on va tuer 1800 requins dans le monde
pour savoir ce qu'il en était vraiment
j'ai eu envie d'étudier tout ce qu'on
racontait sur les requins avec quand
même la ferme intention de les
rencontrer
pourquoi cette peur
ancré au fond de nous bien sûr il ya eu
les médias médias chaque fois qu'il ya
une mort par un requin qui au passage ne
mange pas yg août
il n'aime pas le goût de la chair
humaine
c'est une réalité et comme il n'aime pas
le goût de la chair humaine
il goûte ils mordent sauf que c'est pas
un chaton
la plaie souvent est mortelle mais dix
morts par an et puis il ya aussi eu ce
film culte que vous connaissez tous les
dents de la mer et qui a touché des
générations de personnes qui n'osent
même plus à l'est la mer à cause de ça
mais la peur du requin est ce que c'est
pas un monde condensé de toutes nos
folies de toutes nos peurs et puis un
jour j'ai décidé et bien d'aller à la
rencontre de celui qui fait le plus peur
le grand requin blanc
à cette époque là ce qui avait pas
internet
donc pour faire des recherches s'étaient
pas aussi facile qu'aujourd'hui les
livres les magazines m'ont beaucoup aidé
et je me suis rendu compte que et bien
c'était en afrique du sud que j'avais le
plus de chance de rencontrer des requins
blancs alors j'y suis allé mais voilà en
ce temps là où ne plongeaient pas avec
des requins blancs c'était un animal
considéré comme dangereux et s'attaquant
alors avec un ami sud africain on est
allé voir des pêcheurs de requins
on a discuté je leur ai expliqué que
j'étais venu là pour plonger avec des
requins blancs et m'ont regardé d'une
façon un peu bizarre on a continué à
parlementer
et au bout d'un moment devant ma
détermination
ils ont accepté de construire une
quinzaine bois je la revois cette cage
le font avec des lamelles de bois les
barreaux en bois beaucoup driver ouverte
sur le dessus des plombs en dessous et
des bouées au dessus des bois rose comme
si on les voit bien
et puis un jour on part en mer la cage
sur le bateau on arrive sur un lieu de
pêche m de sa part il met la cage dans
l'eau moi je me prépare ne sont pas très
tranquille je rentre dans la cage
inutile de vous dire que des requins à
pâté elles viennent vous voir
c'est normal et là je n'ai absolument
jamais eu peur j'étais vraiment fasciné
par cet animal et je vous disais mais
c'est quand même un animal en haut de la
chaîne alimentaire et si on le détruit
lui qui a toute sa place dans le monde
sous marin on va créer des désastres
partout on a détruit les requins ça a
été
il ya eu des conséquences épouvantables
je vais vous raconter je suis allé en
1994 en namibie
on avait détruit les requins au motif
qu'ils mangent les poissons au passage
les poissons les requins ne mange que
toutes les deux à trois semaines
mais les requins qui étaient là se
nourrissent et surtout d'otaries plus de
requins les otaries se sont multipliés
et les otaries ça marche quand même un
peu plus de poissons gras cas inutile de
vous dire qu'au bout d'un moment
et bien il y avait une telle
prolifération d'otaries qu'elles sont
mortes de faim avec leurs petits et sur
les plages de namibie il y avait des
carcasses d'otaries un peu partout je ne
vous dis pas l'odeur je suis la tasmanie
nous prenez la tasmanie
on a aussi indiqué les requins mais
aucun qui la base se nourrissait plus
tôt deux poulpes et vous savez très bien
que les poulpes ça se nourrit plutôt de
coquillages et notamment des langoustes
plus de requins les poulpes se sont
multipliés elles ont mangé toutes les
langoustes donc c'est tout le marché qui
s'est écroulé
très vite comme la plupart des rouquines
hologue dont certains sont mes amis j'ai
voulu alerter sur les désastres compte
recourir au monde sous marin en
détruisant les regards 30% aujourd'hui
sont en voie d'extinction et on sait
très bien que la destruction d'un animal
en haut de la chaîne alimentaire va
produire l'effet domino et ça on est
incapable de le gérer
bien sûr qu'il faut protéger les hommes
des requins qui maintenant viennent sur
les côtes parce qu'ils n'ont plus rien
pour se nourrir au large et qui viennent
dans les réserves ou qui viennent manger
nos détritus ce que nous envoyons à la
mer
certains pays ont voulu au nom de la
protection du tourisme met des filets
pour protéger leurs plages je vous ai
dit au début que j'étais curieuse à
l'eau j'ai eu la curiosité d'aller voir
les filets comment il était dans la mer
et là je vous faire une confidence mais
promettez-moi de djamel répéter les
filets sont à un mètre cinquante de
mètres au dessus du fond ce qui veut
dire qu'à la nuit tombée et pendant la
nuit
les requins qui vont vers le rivage
passe de sous les filets d'ailleurs les
requins qui sont prisonniers comme les
tortues des dauphins les ré au passage
le sont toujours
du côté de la côte en revenant vers la
mer
je vais vous faire une petite boutade
imaginons qu'un jour pour une raison
inconnue les filets s'affaisse un petit
peu et que les requins ne puisse plus
repartir
qu'est ce qui va leur rester pour se
nourrir
à votre avis les touristes
ne rajoutons pas aux dents de la mer
détruire tous les requins ça va pas
faire disparaître nos peurs mais c'est
en les connaissant en les respectant
en respectant leur territoire qu'on peut
plus jouer avec eux en toute liberté
même avec le requin blanc c'est quand
même assez extraordinaire
ce requin c'est le seul avec lequel on
pose avec une cage moi j'aime pas trop
en cash et les autres requins qui
pourrait créer les mêmes les mêmes
problèmes on plonge en liberté avec eux
alors j'ai décidé d'aller plonger en
liberté avec le requin blanc et vous
pouvez remarquer 40 ans avec les requins
je suis encore entière et pourtant je
les ai approché de très très près de la
peur de l'eau de la peur du requin
j'en ai fait du positif d'abord vous me
faire plaisir
ensuite pour transmettre une passion et
puis pour militer pour la protection du
monde sous marin
ce monde il est comme nos profondeurs de
l'autre côté du miroir
nous ne voyons pas où nous voulons
l'ignoré mais tout ou tard nos peurs
finissent par nous rattraper et nous
avons tous des peurs et vous avez tous
des peurs vous avez peur de l'eau voyez
j'ai appris à fadel voulu sous marine
vous avez peur des serpents
pourquoi ne pas faire partie d'une
association de protection des serpents
vous avez peur du vide
pourquoi pas faire de la grande roue ou
du saut à l'élastique qui libère par le
cri savez quand on saute à regarder
enfin j'ai fait cette expérience
1 on libère des choses aller à la
rencontre de sa peur c'est d'abord aller
au commencement de ce grain de sable qui
enraye et notre parcours mais sait aussi
se faire confiance et vous avez tous des
moyens de vous faire confiance et de
dépasser vos peurs utiliser sa peur
plutôt que de la fuir la valoriser en
faire une force
ça vous permettre de vivre libres ça va
vous permettre de vous épanouir d'avoir
de nouvelles richesses pour avoir le
bonheur de les partager avec vous et
alors maintenant quelles sont les peurs
que vous allez apprivoiser je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]